hey we're with the man himself John
Stanton you have to carry that in a
fanny pack congratulations on the film
thank you your directorial debut yes so
you filmed in Jordan yes I want to ask
Harry fluent in Arabic no absolutely not
I learned the the big joke I had with
the crew was I would walk in every day
and say estimate John Sherlock shut up
you know ah
okay that's all I had so why should
young people care about press freedom in
their own country than other countries
around the world listen because it's
it's the antidote to ignorance the press
bearing witness doing these types of you
know the bravery as larger news
organisations cut back on infrastructure
you have more of these people out kind
of on their own freelancing and they're
bringing us now the stories that we get
anywhere else
and they should absolutely care about it
obviously this film focused on Iran but
how concerned are you about press
freedom in our very own country here in
the United States well you see now
they're putting you know as the security
apparatus grows sort of unchecked with
the NSA and the CIA
you know there's real concern that the
boundaries between the information that
we should be giving bribe and the
information that they have
are being crossed you know I think
there's cause for real concern so let's
say you have to do another movie
anywhere else in the Middle East about
any other situation or context what
would it be
depends on where Maziar is gonna get
arrested I just gotta wait and see okay
thank you no cinnamon North Korea see
what happens